wir freuen uns herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video hier auf meinem gaming
kanal und ich befinde mich wir schon
sehen können
in meiner neuen wohnung alle die mir
weil sozialen netzwerken folgenden
wissen dass wahrscheinlich schon das
jetzt komplett umgezogen mit in hamburg
allerdings gerade dazu weil eventuelle
fragen habt alles wirklich habe ich
etwas die größten sachen auch was gerade
so hinter den kulissen abläuft sich noch
in filmprojekten planung habe das wo ich
wohne mehr oder wenig erfahrung mich
auch auf den anderen städten bin und
ganz viele andere sachen habe ich mir
dann schnappe ich mir mal den max lkw
kran kraft und mit dem grunde bloß auf
die seht ihr jetzt gleich jeden moment
und ich würde einfach sagen viel spaß
weil ich habe meine brille auf weil ich
gleich auch wieder den urlaub haben
werde und weil ich jetzt einfach beim
auf neben mal aufsetzen muss und auch
beim autofahren und ich würde einfach so
viel spaß aber ich trainieren und
schauen wenn man es irgendwie werden
sollte hallo hallo freunde jetzt sind
wir auch im game nur damit das klar ist
immer so nett sagte button
du hast du sie kommen ohne
daten-flatrate komplett sollte jetzt
bronze bitteschön
ich mache es mir dass ich mich gibt wird
sie sinnvoller dass ich sie das einfach
alles zu werfen hast du erst mal richtig
viel steiler holst nicht schon mal
voraus baute schon mal vor beachtet
jetzt macht laufen denn ich gucke jetzt
läuft ich wollte mich ganz kurz warten
und zwar jetzt schon in dem vor
dingsbums gesehen wo ich ganz kurz
geredet habe was überhaupt stattfinde
werde spielen etwas auf dem plastik
zusammen mit max im einen viermal zweite
milo ist nur noch zu 1 und grün auch
aber die man einfach nur zu einst bist
du nicht einlenken
danke danke ich bitte beachtet michael
schmitz gut denke ich gut
ergibt die allerbesten durchschnitt der
klappe schlägt
nicht ein anderer mit so ich hab da
kommt einer hinter dir dreh dich um
runter newsweek hat wie hast du immer so
viel doch beck alte mine ping und mein
ding und ich schwinge einen pager decken
schwindet schränkt den pendenten denke
was ich sagen wollte war dass ich bei
mir im hintergrund so ein paar dinge
halt also jetzt gerade wirklich im
hintergrund soll wie ihr seht mich im
hintergrund
da seht ihr hier meine palme norbert
hecker das baum ein drache gekommen war
steht von der drahtlos galaxy hat
einfach norbert die pflanze also das ist
normal wird die pflanze und ich bin hier
in der fans komplett aber hintergrund
alle die mir bei twitter folgen wissen
das ist eine neue wohnung in hamburg und
zwar bin ich umgezogen nach hamburg das
war ein nicht sehr langer prozess der
umzug hat einen tag gedauert
also bei allen anderen youtuber die
umziehen dort das extrem lang total
internet probleme also ich war total
zufrieden mit der telekom muss ich so
sagen einfach mal ohne jetzt irgendwie
werbung zu machen es klappt halt alles
50.000 leitungen upload in zehn minuten
fertig er kann seinen 50.000 euro für
dafür dass du sagst wirst du später die
50.000 die wurden jetzt gerade die
moment überwiesen
dann denken wir immer viele bettler da
alles produktplatzierung und dauert es
ist bisher falsch von euch freuen
nee also was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
ist dass ich jetzt wirklich endgültig
umgezogen bin ich dir jetzt auf meinen
eigenen zwei beinen und ja max vorstand
ich auch auf meine zwei beinen
ich dachte ich mir gekrabbelt vorher
wisse genannte später aber es verändert
sich bei mir hat richtig viele dinge
sondern sich halt auf eine beiden jetzt
stehe dass ich jetzt in hamburg leben
das ich jetzt zwei spiele brille
auftragen und die autofahrer aufnehmer
was mich eigentlich stört obwohl sie ja
das haben sogar simon hatte mir schon
weil bei twitter geschrieben dass er die
auch gerne haben würde tun sollte haben
ehrlich ich hab gesagt schenk die idee
nicht mehr braucht es den popo loch von
dem also kappe ich wollte einfach nur so
ein bisschen loswerden dass ich bei mir
halt viel verändert was man nicht auf
den ersten blick mit bekommt also ihr
kommt weil die videos ja ok er macht das
internet aber normalerweise es ist halt
so dass sich bei mir halt total viel
verändert dementsprechend dass ich jetzt
umgezogenen dass ich auch jetzt wenn ihr
mal auf youtube.com schrägstrich luca
geht wird er zweiter gleitet auf meinen
real life kanal auf dem ich mir videos
wieder bald regelmäßig machen
wahrscheinlich wenn ihr das video seht
bin ich schon fleißig wieder abladen
konzepten ich habe schon nach videos
geschaut was er machen könnte da kommt
jemand hatte kate addiert oder wirklich
richtig kaputt gemacht hätte da ist auch
ein halbherziger ich habe sechs gold ich
mache nur einen bogen ich weiß ich jetzt
wegen also bei mir verändert sich halt
viel und ich mach jetzt ich habe auch
gedacht
auf meinem konto after kanal es ist ein
gaming kanal das sagt der name schon und
ich habe mir dann einfach gedacht da
gibt es halt auch abonnenten die halt
kein release sehen wollen die halt
gaming sehen wollen sich trennen das
jetzt luca youtube programm schräg sich
luca ist halt dann mein real life kanal
einfach weil luca ist halt auch
persönlich blabla ist mein name ist das
verbindet man mit real life und hier ist
irgendwo ein gelber typ
das ist gerade voll dass
ok ich sehe wo er steht
weil ich habe hart gekämpft wir sind
beide voll konzentriert ich bin mega
mega den harten kampf mit dem roten haus
tragen
okay ich habe getötet ja dass ich jetzt
das wird jetzt also getrennt also ihr
werdet jetzt auf kontrast keine videos
mehr so an sich wird natürlich gamescom
und so wird natürlich weiter gemacht
aber wenn ihr euch für sowas
interessiert wie beispielsweise eine
room to or for dieser wohnung oder wenn
ihr noch ein paar fakten über mich haben
wollte so wie beispielsweise es ihr
einfach mehr über mich bist mehr über
mich kennen lernt mich kennen lernt weiß
nicht mag das eigentlich so wenn man
fakten wie das macht über mich selber
also wenn ich das manchmal und ich habe
auch mit mit kathi von von dem buben
beim netzwerk habe ich ein paar konzepte
ausgearbeitet die ich denke ich ganz gut
umsetzen könnte wo ich auch richtig bock
drauf habe richtig gas zu geben auf ein
real fk ich habe gold für dich hab acht
gold macht ein paar konzepte
ausgearbeitet mit richtig viel kunst auf
einem realen kanal
aber das sind halt alles so sachen die
ihr halt nicht mitbekommt die allerdings
gerade los sind bei mir und das ihr halt
nicht denkt dass ich hier nur umsätze
und jetzt studiere sondern dass ich mich
halt auch schon noch um youtube kümmern
das ist wichtig dass edith und vom teams
und das wollte ich nur sagen ja kein
ding das wollte ich halt nur eben sagen
unterhalt auch beispielsweise ich hatte
einen designer aus russland
angeschrieben wladimir und die sind die
seiten mir halt sondern meinen minecraft
kind aber so richtig cool und ich bin so
wie das normale designer machen sondern
das wirklich echt ganz cool
und da wird dann bald neues profilbild
kommen bei meinem konto kraft und neues
branding und neue nicht neues am nails
weil ich mit dem zufrieden
das ist oft verhindert
ich habe ihn runter geschaltet wird gut
ja ich weiss nicht verändert sich bei
mir halt derzeit ziemlich viel und es
bekommt halt man nicht so direkt mit
eigentlich als einer damit mit patrick
scales hacker wegen vettel
übrig sie natürlich kriegst du kriegst
du ihn nicht das ist ein kampf
die haben aber die mitte ich weiß nicht
das ist so ein klappbett mittlere ganzen
situation ja ich weiss nicht also das
wollte ich halt sagen dass ich jetzt in
hamburg wurde dass der mit total
zufrieden mit der wohnung mit alles
mögliche und ob im studium nur was ich
halt sagen wollte ist dass ich auch sehr
auf den konten bin also dass die mich da
auch sehr auf 10 werde die mutter
letztes schon zweimal bei subway und
noch in der innenstadt kann als sie mit
dem kumpel mit moni kollegen war nach
köln einfach so gefahren als sie
mitgenommen hatte ich habe mir mit max
auch schon mal in köln gewohnt in der
bruchbuden hotel absteigen wären dem
video days und köln ist echt eine schöne
stadt aber deswegen will ich nicht hier
sondern ich bin halt hier weil einfach
mein netzwerk die wii besitzt eigentlich
zwar in berlin
und wir haben uns halt auch in berlin
schon mal getroffen mit gattin war dabei
dadurch auch eine tugend macht ihr wisst
was ich meine
die videos habt ihr wahrscheinlich
gesehen all der ersten liga zwei unsere
pace
allerdings haben wir jetzt halt so
gesagt vom netzwerk ausdauer opels re
wie justin max und so viele kommen halt
aus köln oder umgebung und deswegen
wollten jetzt öfters mal in köln treffen
ich bin auch wegen paar sachen öfters
mal köln deswegen werde ich mich auch
oft in köln sehen also da werde ich auch
oft seien allerdings werde ich halt
immer noch in hamburg wohnen bleiben und
alle hamburger die dabei muss
hierbleiben zu bleiben ja natürlich
das sind halt aber einfach so dinge die
ich euch einfach mal sagen wollte und
ich möchten wir so lange ich haben schon
sechs minuten drüber gelabert oder sogar
noch länger oder acht und ist verändert
sich viel und ihr werdet fiel auf meinem
real life kanal davon mitbekommen und
auch viel wird sich so verändern
allerdings hält sich auch viel verändert
das egal ich mitbekommen und das wollte
ich einfach nur sagen dass ich da nicht
einfach nur rum ziele
und ja das war eigentlich mein anliegen
so die spieler etwas max wollen wir uns
einen energy-drink machen ist dass die
anwendung wenn du erklären kannst wir
das ganz gut weil ich glaube
schnelligkeit ist nicht falsch wenn wir
die ganze zeit diesen
der hallenboden und will hat er nie
einfach mal weil jetzt ist frei das habe
ich ja ich hab ja auch im bogen machen
du hast den bogen oder du hast ein
konflikt mit dem situation er wollte
wissen ob einer provider ich habe die
steine kam keine okay leute jetzt kriegt
ihr so auf eure rosenheim beste alter
ich hab nicht mal scheiße ich habe ihn
noch nie so schlimm nicht so schlimm und
die haben sie so ich möchte ich die
ganze zeit ist mir ein persönliches
anliegen die jetzt kaputt zu machen
aber du hast kein keinen bogen hast
gesagt ich habe oben kommen schnell geht
auf asterix aber ich kann nicht in
schach halten
kg ist auf die bmw dreht den spieß um du
gehst aber auf die und ich gebe mir
sehen wo ich mein zeug auf mehr
nur ich hab da ich gehe mal ganz kurz
wieder zurück immerhin allerdings noch
hier einen ball nicht dass die mich
jetzt mal eben die dann von der seite
daher springen weil ich danach unter
boxen guten deine sachen ich mache jetzt
genauso wie die einfach er hat einfach
total es total voll mit fallen und wenn
er jetzt mal irgendwie bei ausbleiben
oder so es ist jetzt zwar aber das haben
die einfach auch gerade gemacht so endet
kacke die wissen was sie verloren haben
ich bin schon wieder komplett
ausgerüstet kommissar homo ich kombiheck
voll ausgerüstet ich komm junge habe
sein okay ich bin am start ich hab einen
fix dabei so leute hinein schnee
doch glatt fünf leute nichts klar okay
leute kommen mit luca kommentar ist zeit
für eine rache von blut was auch der
wird jetzt bestimmt zu uns kommen wollen
ich halte hier bisschen okay ein hab ich
getötet der andere ich bin runter
gefallen aber aber ich konnte mich nur
zu uns kommen
ja ich habe in ordnern runter wenn er
hier rüber kommt kannst wenn du irgendwo
hingehen willst er kommt wirklich zu uns
strand argument gesucht das war spitze
war eine gute runde war sogar genau dann
zu ende gegangen wo ich werde mit den
themen hat mir sehr gut gefallen wenn
ihr bei maximal schauen wollt weil max
ist echt gut im pvp und mehr sein weil
ich geschafft canalis in der oben
vielleicht eine schreiben oder ganz
unten ich glaube ich verlinke ich mal
nach ganz unten
du bist gut sein ich habe ganz unten
verlinkt
überall werde tagsüber seine fische so
gut
ich würde sagen das war es dann mit
diesem video es war eventuell bisschen
nächsten strukturiert ich habe zuerst
ein bisschen geld nur ich weiß halt
nicht was das video ist gebracht hat ich
wollte euch einfach mal nur sagen dass
sich bei mir relativ viel verändert hat
in meinem leben und ich froh bin dass
youtube zumindest gleichgeblieben ist
wollen sie die süße aber später wagte
nacht hinter der spitze aber ja wenn es
euch gefallen hat zeigt es uns mit einer
bewertung und sonst kommen dann in
zukunft wieder also diese anderen serien
wie top 5 irgendwas oder kräftige den
oder facts und da hatte ich solche bvb
hat er weniger mit dem pvp aber all das
sehen wir dann anders